[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro i got a big hour plan for you so
this hour because we are now five days
from the election i'm gonna make the
case for president trump along the lines
of his policies we're gonna talk about
all the things that trump has done
because
i understand all the media i want to
talk about is all the dumb stuff trump
tweets i get it
i mean it's easy media coverage as a
member of the media the easiest story
that you can write on any given day
is the story where trump tweeted
something dumb and then you have that be
the entire news cycle for the entire day
and you ask all republicans about what
trump said and they're like oh isn't he
a racist and
everybody says no he's not a racist or i
haven't seen that tweet and this is the
easiest job
in the media the hard job in the media
is actually digging down
into the stuff that is actually
happening on the presidential level
because the fact is the trump
administration's record
has been wildly successful i mean
extremely successful on domestic policy
on foreign policy on regulatory policy
on economic policy
when it comes to this administration
there has never been a bigger divide in
american history
between the rhetoric of an
administration and the actual activities
of the administration that doesn't mean
that all of trump's rhetoric is bad i've
criticized trump's rhetoric when i
thought it was bad i criticized him over
his original comments
at charlottesville which i thought were
wildly insufficient i've criticized
trump
on his comments about mexican judges or
about where el hanomar comes from and
that sort of stuff but here is the
reality
trump has also expressed opposition to
some of the most nefarious forces in
american life from the 1619 project
to the multiculturalist attempt to treat
all cultures as
as uniquely deserving of praise
and not all of trump's rhetoric has been
bad some of it has been very bad
much of it has been very good and in
some cases uniquely good so this hour
we are going to go through all of
trump's accomplishments ranging from the
ideological
to the actual practical because i think
that again the easiest thing is to focus
in on the personality of the candidate
that is the easiest thing in the world
to do it is a lazy trick
okay it is a lazy trick to simply look
at two candidates and say which one
would i rather have a beer with or which
one do i think is nicer or which one
would make a better grandpa like that's
none of that is relevant to the question
of which direction should the country go
in terms of policy
and ideology and philosophy you can come
down on any side of these questions but
you should at least be fully informed
and your friends and family should be
fully informed
of what exactly the trump administration
has done because my guess is they like a
lot of the things he has done they just
don't want to acknowledge it
okay so let's start with president trump
and his and his domestic policy we'll
get to foreign policy in a little bit
so on domestic policy trump has been
wildly successful
his economic record is virtually
unparalleled for the last half century
so there's been a lot of talk about more
jobs being created under obama
okay but there are many more people on
the sidelines under obama it turns out
that one of the hardest things to do in
a labor market
is to take a labor market that is
gradually moving
and then move it that additional margin
up to wild success and that is what
trump has actually done
wages were rising faster under trump in
three years than he did for eight under
obama
most of those gains in terms of wage
increases
were actually happening
disproportionately at the bottom half of
the scale
okay the fact is that americans were
doing unprecedentedly well
under donald trump's economy until
coveted hit and the reason for that is
obvious
donald trump cut taxes donald trump cut
regulations donald trump created an
environment
where people felt safe and secure
investing in their workers investing in
their business
there's a lot of money trillions of
dollars sitting on the sidelines during
the obama administration
because you just didn't know what
confiscatory policy obama was going to
pursue at any given moment
was it worth hiring somebody only to
have your taxes increased next month
was it worth staffing up only in order
to have to fire half of those people
when the economy downturned was it worth
investing in marketing knowing that the
market could go soft in any moment
because barack obama's policy was so
variable and so
generally anti-business under barack
obama we had the slowest recovery in the
history of the united states under
donald trump
the economy continued to accelerate and
accelerated much faster
under trump than it did under obama this
is true in terms of wages particularly
it is true in terms of living standards
it is true in terms of
the the unemployment rate under barack
obama was significantly higher on
average than it was under donald trump
by the time
of the election uh by the time of covid
we had the lowest unemployment rate
for the last 50 years so yes donald
trump's economic record
is excellent his economic record was
really really really good
up until covet hit what you'll see
is a bunch of people attempting to
downplay trump's economy
but that is really wrong-headed
everybody who runs a business knows
there is a difference between operating
in the trump era and operating in the
obama era
and you could see that right until 2020
trump's first term was characterized by
solid job growth right this is something
that cnn
acknowledges hilariously they say at
this point in obama's presidency the job
market was up
0.4 percent okay well he took
office at a time when we were at the
bottom of the recession
donald trump escalated the the
employment in the country at a time when
we were already escalating employment
which is actually a harder thing to do
median income under donald trump rose
tremendously
9.2 percent
under donald trump that's the median
income data until 2019.
under barack obama over the course of
his entire presidency it rose five
percent
okay that is absolutely true that means
median income median american household
income
was up 5 800 bucks from 2016 after
adjusting
for inflation the pandemic obviously
took the wind out of the sales but that
is the reason the the economy by the way
is recovering this quarter we had a 33
gdp growth this quarter why because
people understand that the underlying
fundamentals of the economy are still
strong it's just that kovid
meant that everybody had to stay home
the
the stock market under donald trump
continued to rise
incredible incredibly steadily
okay trump's economy was historically
good
historically good and there's no other
way to cut it
manufacturing jobs under donald trump
increased
a gross domestic product under donald
trump increased at a significantly
faster rate like
wildly outpacing barack obama in the
early years of his term
okay so all of the talk about trump's
economy not being all that good it was
really really good up until march
obviously and one of the reasons for
that is because he did radically cut
regulation
diane katz writing for the heritage
foundation back in
2018 october 17 2018 about two years ago
writes the trump administration on
wednesday reported 23 billion dollars in
savings
from 176 deregulatory actions in fiscal
year 2018.
even more consequential the
administration has issued 65
fewer significant rules those with costs
that exceed 100 million
a year than the obama administration 51
fewer than the bush administration after
22 months
in office naomi rao who is an
administrator of the office of
information and regulatory affairs now
she is a judge
on one of the circuit courts she said in
modern times
the expansion of the administrative
state has placed undue burdens on the
public impeding economic growth
technological innovation and consumer
choice our reform efforts emphasized the
rule of law respect for the
constitution's separation of powers and
the limits of agency authority
this all resulted in fewer man-hours
being spent complying with regulations
which means more man-hours spent
on actual productive activity the
administration in 2018 took 57
significant deregulatory actions
compared to 14
significant regulatory actions according
to the information and regulatory
affairs office data
that is a massive change in the number
of costly regulations after 22 months in
office
under barack obama 647 costly
regulations under trump 229
costly regulations annual regulatory
costs under the obama administration
increased by 122 billion dollars by the
way
the administration the administration
capped its regulatory costs
at 18 billion so the cuts in regulations
radically increased the possibilities
for american businesses
and those cuts in regulatory action
included allowing small businesses and
sole proprietors to join together as
associations
to purchase healthcare coverage for
employees which was a cost saving
measure prohibited under obamacare
reducing red tape for skilled nursing
facilities hospitals and home health
care providers
streamlining approval for applications
for fracking
expanding exemptions to the obamacare
contraceptive coverage mandate for
religious beliefs
right all this stuff was really really
good stuff cutting regulations is a
radically underestimated part
of the trump record that was really
really good
another part of the the trump record
that was really really good
were the tax cuts the tax cuts cut taxes
for people across the board which is why
now joe biden
when he says he's going to repeal the
trump tax cuts he finally admitted he
means he's only going to repeal part of
the trump tax cuts because it turns out
that those trump tax cuts
helped pretty much everybody on the
income spectrum so long as you're
making an income and paying income tax
in the united states an income tax cut
under president trump's tax plan helped
you in fact the only people attended to
hurt were high income earners in blue
states
people like me when i was living in
california here was president trump
announcing the tax cuts 3.2 trillion
dollars
in tax cuts for american families
including the doubling of the standard
deduction and the doubling
of the child tax credit
the typical family of four earning 75
we see an income tax cut of more than 2
000 many much higher than that slashing
their tax bill
in half and they're going to start to
see that because we're signing today
they're going to start to see that in
february and this all contributed again
to average hourly earnings rising
fairly dramatically under donald trump
like much more dramatically under donald
trump than they did
under barack obama the poverty rate as
of 2019 was at an all-time low in the
united states
about 4.2 million fewer people were
living in poverty in the united states
in 2019
compared to 2018. okay that is a major
again these tax cuts which were
supposedly just for the rich people they
weren't just for the rich people they
really really helped the economy
cut regulation cut taxes
okay and then he obviously used
his presidential power to appoint
originalist judges to the best of his
ability i mean like
hundreds and hundreds of them this is
largely to the credit of mitch mcconnell
and the federalist society advisors who
put together the list on behalf of
president trump in the middle by the
middle of 2020 by the middle of this
year by june
the senate had confirmed trump's 200th
judicial nominee
mcconnell noted that in addition to
being trump's 200th judicial nominee
there were no more vacancies on the
country's influential appeals courts
so all these vacancies have been filled
by trump and republican senate
senator chuck grassley the former
chairman and current member of the
judiciary committee added he expected
trump's nominees to be in the mold
of the late supreme court justice
antonin scalia
he said this landmark achievement is the
result of the president keeping his word
and the unwavering determination of
leader mcconnell chairman graham that'd
be lindsey graham of the judiciary
committee and our conference
republicans have set a record pace
according to the hill at confirming
trump's appeals court nominees
including breaking a record for the
number of picks confirmed during an
administration's first and second year
in office and again the reason for this
is because harry reid nuked the
filibuster
on judicial nominees claiming that it
was necessary in order to get through
obama's nominees
trump has filled an enormous number of
judicial positions with people who
actually give a damn about the
constitution which is a radical
difference from obama judges
obama judges typically believe that they
get to look into their own hearts
and their own souls and decide what the
law is based on which on what they wish
the law were trump's judges generally do
not do this
and of course this is most obvious when
it comes to his supreme court picks
despite disappointments with neil
gorsuch with regard to his
interpretation of the civil rights act
and his attempt to read transgenderism
into the title ix provisions of the
civil rights act which is bizarre
gorsuch overall is still a textualist
justice kavanaugh is still a textualist
amy coney barrett looks to be an
originalist okay these are all
significantly better than if hillary
clinton had been president
here was president trump announcing the
various justices that he had picked for
the supreme court just as a reminder
this was a major thing today i am
keeping another promise
to the american people by nominating
judge neil gorsuch so was that a
surprise
was it judge brett kavanaugh
[Applause]
judge amy coney barrett
okay each one of these justices has
expressed their fealty to the text of
the constitution to the original meaning
of the constitution
they've expressed their fealty to the
belief that the judiciary is not
supposed to be a branch of government
that quote unquote does policy
it is a branch of government that
interprets the law as written doesn't
mean they'll always get it right it
means they're going to do a hell of a
lot better
than the democrats would have appointed
democrats appointees
generally do not care about the law as
written they care much more when it
comes to the constitution
about something very different they care
much more about the political priorities
of democrats which is why ruth bader
ginsburg could be counted on
in any pinch to do the work of whatever
democratic president
was in office we are going through
president trump's policy successes this
entire hour so we've been going through
his domestic policy successes we have
talked about his cuts to regulations
we've talked about his appointment of
hundreds of judges to the federal
judiciary
we've talked about his tax cuts which
jogged the economy
well it didn't stop there president
trump has also appointed pro-life people
to the executive branch and he's pursued
pro-life policies so for example
he reinstated the mexico city policy to
prevent taxpayer funding of abortions
overseas
he signed an executive order stating
that faith-based employers and
organizations like little sisters of the
poor
could not be forced to violate religious
beliefs to comply with obamacare
remember
the obama administration literally sued
nuns in order to get them to cover
contraceptive care
remember this trump undid that he
implemented new rules to prevent title
family planning groups from getting
funding federally
for abortion he called on congress to
pass a ban on late-term abortions
he insisted that faith-based entities be
included in the
cares act paycheck protection program be
eligible for funding so like churches
would not go under
during the covid crisis and he's
defended various religious people
from having their religious beliefs
violated when states attempted to go
after them
for failures to abide by the social
structures that the left prefers
all of that is really really important
stuff all of that would be undone under
biden
joe biden does not care about religious
freedom not in any real way shape or
form
joe biden is much more focused on the
social left agenda and cramming it down
on everybody who engages in business and
happens to be religious
okay also importantly he restored due
process on college campuses
so title ix restrictions had been used
to basically suggest that colleges were
allowed to run these kangaroo courts
where if somebody was accused of sexual
assault or sexual harassment on a
college campus
you couldn't defend yourself there were
these star chamber courts where
essentially you're accused of something
you don't get to confront the accuser
you don't really get to testify on your
own behalf in many cases you don't get
the evidence produced against you
and the standard of proof is basically
nil and you get kicked out of school
anybody can allege anything it was
really really horrible
under the barack obama administration
that was redone betsy devos's secretary
the secretary of education the
department of education they redid
the the way the due process is performed
on college campuses under title ix here
is betsy devos announcing that change
justice without fairness is no justice
at all
so the way to a better title ix justice
process is not to
undermine rights but to uphold them
the way to a better process is not to
reform it but to replace it
the way to put an end to the crisis of
confidence on too many campuses
is to rediscover the fundamentals of our
founding
on which our framers staked their
futures for the sake of ours
okay that of course is exactly right she
was ripped up and down for this it was a
gutsy decision by betsy devos in the
department of education but a very very
important one
because the left has basically suggested
that if you want to process this means
that you're
speaking up on behalf of toxic
masculinity that is not right you
process
everyone is entitled to it i know a lot
of folks on the left don't necessarily
believe that
they believe that cops should
immediately be hauled before courts for
the
evil of having done their jobs in many
cases they believe
that if you are justice brett kavanaugh
being slandered with allegations of gang
rape should be enough to borrow you from
the federal bench
but the trump administration has pushed
hard for due process
speaking of policing the trump
administration has been very supportive
of police across the country unlike the
obama administration which crammed down
ridiculous consent decrees that achieved
nothing
and actually increased crime rates in
major cities across the country
the uh the trump administration has done
no such thing the trump administration
has stood by police
as well they should we'll get to sort of
ideological difference
ideological differences between the
trump administration and the obama
administration in just a second then we
get to what i think
may be actually the most important
accomplishment of the trump
administration and i know
that trump has been bashed to hell and
back over his coveted response
the reality is no one on the left can
explain what they would have done
differently
really no one all they say is wear masks
a lot hey the masking
data is mixed mass mandates have not
prevented massive increases in caseload
all across europe
they've not stopped increased caseload
in places like france or germany or
italy or
virtually any place else that does not
mean that masking isn't useful in
certain particular situations you're in
close contact with someone for 20
minutes that person is vulnerable
then it's useful okay but that is really
the only thing that democrats can hang
their mask on so to speak
their their covid response has been
entirely in favor of
lockdowns which are bad and have now
been condemned by the who
they say they will they will push
vaccines
but it was trump they created operation
warp speed and its democrats who are now
saying that they won't approve any
vaccine approved by trump
it it was it was trump who got the ppe
and the ventilators where they needed to
go the most important accomplishment
that trump made during kova though
was that he refused to take control via
the federal government of every aspect
of americans life
you know if a democrat were in charge we
would have been talking about national
lockdowns
you know if a democrat were in charge
they would have used every ability at
their disposal in order to seize control
of private
means of production there was a call to
do that through the defense production
act
trump refused it he said these companies
are working with us there's no reason
that we need to seize control of these
companies
he was right the fact that trump's first
response
to the single greatest opportunity for a
government power grab
of my lifetime was not to make that
power grab is a great indicator he is
not quite the fascist or tyrant that the
left likes to make him out to be
the left would have grabbed power in a
heartbeat they have in california
in new york in new jersey trump didn't
do that and for that he deserves
enormous credit because he was getting
extraordinary blowback and the easiest
thing in the world would have been for
him to say okay you guys want me to take
control i'm taking control
he didn't that is a good thing this is a
federalist country
states and localities ought to be the
first line of defense against this sort
of stuff and not every state and not
every locality ought to be treated
exactly the same when it comes to
coveted restrictions
good for trump on that score so we are
going through president trump's
accomplishments in his first term in
office we've gone through his domestic
policy
now it's time to get to the even better
stuff that he's done which is his
foreign policy trump's foreign policy
has been
excellent like really really good i
understand that people thought that
trump was going to be a disaster on
foreign policy and there are areas of
foreign policy where i really disagree
with trump's approach particularly north
korea
i don't think that winding and dining
kim jong-un and writing love letters or
anything like that
is good foreign policy however on
everything else
he's been much much stronger than barack
obama barack obama wanted to reduce the
military it's why he insisted
on trillion dollar cuts to the military
in the middle of sequestration
he he insisted that the military be cut
down to the bare bones he insisted on
making it so that our
our military was incapable of fighting a
two-front conflict
and donald trump has rebuilt the
military we have sunk enormous sums of
cash
into rebuilding the military at the same
time
he's actually created unprecedented
peace and prosperity in regions
that have not seen it in quite a while
so his most obvious accomplishments have
been in the middle east
so on a personal level i have great
appreciation as a jew for the fact that
donald trump
moved the embassy in israel from tel
aviv to jerusalem that was something
that
people had suggested they were going to
do for decades congress had approved it
trump actually did it trump in doing
that bucked
decades of conventional foreign policy
wisdom that said that the arab street
was going to rise on mass that arabs
cared
everywhere about where the united states
placed its embassy that by legitimizing
the jewish claim to jerusalem this was
somehow a violation
of all peaceful norms it was going to
lead to
wild violence in the streets none of
that happened trump recognized the truth
jerusalem is the undivided capital of
israel it will remain the undivided
capital
of israel and the united states doesn't
get to decide where israel has its
capital israel gets to divide where it
decide where it has its capital but it
didn't stop there
this was actually the the beginning
point
of a breakout of peace in the middle
east that we have not seen in several
decades
it actually was okay so here was what
happened donald trump moved the embassy
to jerusalem
nothing happened donald trump recognized
that the golan heights were sovereign
israeli territory they were not disputed
territory they were not owned by the
assad regime in syria nothing happened
donald trump recognized that the
settlements in judea and samaria the
so-called settlements in the west bank
were not de facto illegal under
international law which of course is
true
nothing happened and it became obvious
to everyone
that the arab nations are not primarily
concerned with bolstering
the the warful aspirations
of the palestinian authority hamas and
islamic jihad that the terrorist
leadership of the palestinians
had not wanted to make peace that all of
their goals on peace had nothing to do
with territory
it had nothing to do with actually
achieving a palestinian state it was all
directed at violence
is directed at violence against israel
and the destruction of the state of
israel
and the arab nations had more to gain
through peace with israel than by
continuing to back the violence of the
palestinians and the palestinian
authority
and that became absolutely clear when
nothing happened and the next step
was a peace agreement between israel and
the united arab emirates followed by a
peace agreement between israel and sudan
and a peace agreement between israel and
kosovo and there are peace agreements
all over the middle east now
right there are peace agreements that
are happening bahrain that are happening
all over the middle east right now
and the reason that that stuff is
happening and more are coming morocco is
on the docket saudi arabia is on the
docket
the reason that is happening is because
donald trump had the balls frankly
speaking
to dump over conventional foreign policy
wisdom suggesting
that the centrality of the
israeli-palestinian issue that only if
israel made concessions to the
terrorist palestinian leadership would
peace break out in the middle east until
then
the arab nations would remain in a state
of constant war with israel
and they would continue to oppose the
united states turns out that's not true
it turns out
that donald trump's willingness to buck
conventional foreign policy wisdom
was wisdom it was smart it was correct
he hasn't gotten proper credit for that
he should get proper credit for that it
is also true by the way
that his willingness to express that
what the middle east is not
a quote unquote honest broker between a
westernized liberal country like israel
and terrorists like the palestinian
authority
what is necessary is for the west to
overtly side with its allies and say
these are our allies and we will back
them and if you would like us to back
you too
if you would like us to provide you with
all of the tender mercies that the west
can offer then perhaps you should get on
board
also worth noting this was the
unintentional side effect and
consequence of barack obama's garbage
foreign policy elevating iran
to a status of a regional power it turns
out that when you elevate the mullahs
everybody who is on the mueller's hit
list is going to side with israel
against the mullahs here was donald
trump announcing
some of these peace deals after 49 years
israel and the united
arab emirates will fully normalize their
diplomatic relations
they will exchange embassies and
ambassadors and begin cooperation
across the board by uniting two of
america's closest and most capable
partners in the region
something which said could not be done
this deal is a significant step towards
building a more peaceful
secure and prosperous middle east
okay so that was obviously a historic
moment he's not gotten proper credit for
that if barack obama had done it he
would have won his second nobel prize
given that he won one just for breathing
and being a human okay so that
was actually an accomplishment that is a
major major thing these are the first
major peace deals in the region
in 30 years certainly since uh certainly
since
1994 and the jordanian peace deal
okay but frankly i think these are just
as important if not more important
because it's full of normalization it's
recognition of israel's right to exist
it's full normalization that's a
different thing than jordan simply
saying we're not going to
exist in a constant state of open
warfare with our neighbors
okay meanwhile he cracked down on iran
he dumped out of the idiotic iran deal
the iran deal was a lie that was
voiced it on the american people by the
obama administration the lie was there
were moderates in iran who would be
emboldened
if the united states signed over
billions of dollars and opened the gates
to hundreds of billions of dollars in
commerce to an iranian terrorist regime
that supported the murder of american
soldiers in iraq supported the
full-scale destruction of the state of
israel
supported the overthrow of the saudi
regime right the obama administration
said you can use that money for
terrorism fine just
promise us that you're not going to
develop nukes for 10 years okay that is
not a deal
that is a surrender trump dumped out of
it it set the stage for sanctions on
iran
it set the stage for the weakening of
the iranian regime and it set the stage
for an actual alliance against iran that
included both jews and arabs
this is trump dumping out of the iran
deal in may of 2018.
in just a short period of time the
world's leading state sponsor of terror
will be on the cusp of acquiring the
world's
most dangerous weapons therefore
i am announcing today that the united
states
will withdraw from the iran
nuclear deal today's action
sends a critical message the united
states
no longer makes empty threats
okay well that was a that was a very
good thing and it turned out the united
states did not make empty threats
that trump made again the ballsy move of
killing hassan solomonia soleimani was
in iraq he was fostering violence
against american troops and against
american bases in iraq he was not in
iran
he was the head of iran's terror
apparatus and trump killed him
and trump unleashed a hellfire missile
and silemani ended up in pieces
that was a ballsy call joe biden opposed
it
donald trump is responsible for the
killing of al-baghdadi the head of isis
in the middle east
after the obama administration turned
isis from the so-called jv team that's
how obama described them
into an actual regional power i mean
they had they controlled territory
larger than the size of the uk the obama
administration started to fight back
the trump administration radically
accelerated that and then of course
trump killed all baghdadi and isis was
reduced to rubble
so all of that's in the middle east that
was all good middle eastern policy from
president trump
furthermore president trump recognized
china as a threat so
the bush administration the obama
administration all of them treated china
as basically a competitor a strategic
competitor but not a threat
right they weren't people who were
really out to to
subvert democracy they weren't people
who were out to maximize their own power
at the cost of the west
they weren't folks who were attempting
to exacerbate their own regional
influence
through pure intimidation but trump
recognized exactly what it was that
china was doing china has been
exploiting trade rules in order to
enrich itself it's been cheating
china has been radically expanding its
military presence in the south china sea
and trump recognized that and trump
decided that it was time to actually
strike back
at chinese economic source of power
we must hold accountable the nation
which unleashed this plague
unto the world china in the earliest
days of the virus
china locked down travel domestically
while allowing flights to leave
china and infect the world later they
falsely said people without symptoms
would not spread the disease the united
nations must hold
china accountable for their actions
okay so good for him because china
is a bad actor on the world stage i mean
it is incredible that we have watched in
the last several years trying to overtly
take over a democratic hong kong
like literally just take it over walk
right in and take it over and the rest
of the world did nothing
what do you think joe biden is going to
do you think joe biden is going to stand
up strong to the chinese he can't even
declare
that china is an enemy he says they're
not even a competitor by the way he says
that the chances that they eat our
launch are now
meanwhile china is already fostering
parties inside taiwan in an attempt to
get taiwan to overthrow its own
democratically elected government
china is on the march and trump at least
gets that much
meanwhile trump also dumped out of the
idiotic paris accords the paris accords
were set
to crumble the american economy like a
piece of kleenex
the paris accords would not alleviate
climate change in any serious way
even if all nations abided by the paris
accords it would marginally lower the
temperature over the course of the next
century
from its from its perspective warmth
the paris accords were not being abided
by by india they were not being abided
by by china
trump jumped out of them because they
are in fact stupid the paris accords are
a piece of paper
in which a bunch of countries pretend
that they're going to reduce their
carbon emissions while not reducing
their carbon emissions and uh they've
been held up by democrats as some sort
of grand foreign policy achievement they
are not
they were an excuse to cut down on
america's oil industry and her fracking
industry and her manufacturing
here was president trump talking about
dumping out of the the paris accords
the paris climate accord is simply the
latest example of washington
entering into an agreement that
disadvantages
the united states to the exclusive
benefit of other countries
leaving american workers who i love
and taxpayers to absorb the cost
in terms of lost jobs lower wages
shuttered factories
and vastly diminished economic
production
he is correct about this okay and the
left one nuts over it and the fact is
again the paris accords were completely
useless they were an empty
piece of paper they were a big nothing
and then the left says oh well you know
it's so bad that he got out of it
yeah on foreign policy i think it is
also worth noting that donald trump has
not started
any new wars isn't that kind of a thing
i mean there's not been a president in
my lifetime who hasn't started any new
wars
the the war in yugoslavia was a clinton
war
putting troops on the ground in somalia
that was a clinton war
george w bush of course did not start
the war in afghanistan that was response
to 9 11.
the war in iraq was a bush
administration move the obama
administration fought an
unconstitutional war in libya
where america had essentially no foreign
policy interest whatsoever and of course
he pursued a massive drone campaign that
was firmly ignored by the left
for years on end the fact that trump has
not started any new wars is kind of an
accomplishment is it not
i know that we ignore all of that but
for a guy who's supposed to be a
tyrannical warmonger he doesn't seem
like all that much of a tyrant or
warmonger
it's just something i'm noticing trump
has actually lessened the amount of
control the federal government exerts
over your life domestically
and he has lessened america's reliance
on war making
on foreign policy so i'm wondering he
was supposed to be hitlerian
i'm wondering where the record of that
is like seriously
none of this is deny he says dumb crap
president says dumb crap
fact also he has not been a warmonger
he's brought
an enormous amount of good to the middle
east he has stood up to the russians
he's stood up to the chinese
he's done many things that i'm always
amazed by the talk about russia by the
way
donald trump has actually maintained
sanctions on russia donald trump has
stood with eastern europe against
russian predations
barack obama allowed the russians to
march into crimea with nothing happening
barack obama overtly handed over syria
to the russians
the disconnect between trump's actual
performance and the way that he is
covered by the media and by his enemies
is
extraordinary extraordinary okay in just
a second we're going to get to
some actual good rhetoric by president
trump because i think perhaps the
largest difference between trump and his
opponents
is that on a baseline level trump does
not believe that america is a bad place
on a baseline level the democratic party
has moved in the direction of the 1619
project
they've moved in the direction of a
perceived multiculturalism that suggests
that america
is no better than any other place donald
trump has been a ringing rebuke to that
i don't think that he represents it the
best way that it could be represented
but i think that he has had some real
high
rhetoric moments i think we ignore those
because of the dumb twitter comments
but it was worth remembering them
because in the long run
expression of those values is quite
important so when it comes to trump's
rhetoric i've been highly critical and i
think justifiably so i think his tweets
have gotten him in a lot of trouble i
think that if they had flushed his
phone down the toilet within the first
two days of his election donald trump
would be cruising to re-election
right now i think that he has done
himself no favors
through his rhetorical excesses uh
through his inability to control his
messaging and all the rest
it is worthy of note that donald trump
has from time to time
issued some very important statement on
american values doesn't mean that trump
himself is necessarily the best
representative of those values at all
times it does mean the statements are
worthy of note
because there is a left on the march in
the united states that despises american
philosophy
wants to see american statues torn down
believes that america
is inherently a racist terrible place
this is a democratic party that
full-scale embraces the 16-19 project
which suggests that the true founding of
the united states was not
in freedom and liberty in 1776 and in
fact was something very very different
so president trump famously spoke at
mount rushmore he gave what i thought
was an
absolutely unobjectionable speech not
only unobjectionable
necessary speech talking about american
values and their enduring purpose and
principle
and talking about the evils of a
disintegrationist philosophy that wishes
to tear down the nation
on the false basis that america is
racist sexist bigoted and homophobic
from its roots
here was donald trump and mount rushmore
in what i think was probably the most
important speech of his presidency
those who seek to erase our heritage one
americans to forget our pride and our
great
dignity so that we can no longer
understand
ourselves or america's destiny
in toppling the heroes of 1776
they seek to dissolve the bonds of love
and loyalty
that we feel for our country and that we
feel for each other
their goal is not a better america their
goal is to
end america he is not wrong about this
and the fact that trump was willing to
speak that out loud is definitely a good
thing
because the left is on the march and joe
biden has been putting out these very
patriotic ads right it's got all of the
stock footage oh look some waving grain
oh look it's an american flag with the
sunlight shining through it oh look it's
a father helping his son at a baseball
game
okay but let's be real the heart and
soul of the democratic party is not with
the joe biden appeals to patriotism at
this point it is with the alexander
ocasio-cortez
and the ohana omar and the rashida talib
it is with the
radicals in the democratic party who
believe that america is not a great
place that america is in fact a quite
terrible place and in fact joe biden
from time to time has said this
he said literally we have never lived up
to our ideals never in american history
have we lived up to our ideals
which is an amazing statement for a
country that freed europe of tyranny
twice
for a country that was responsible for
ending slavery within its own borders
via a massive civil war
for a country that was responsible for a
civil rights movement
that elevated a a
victimized racial minority to legally
required rights i mean that was a
righteous crusade
this country has very often lived up to
its ideals but democrats don't but
here's the thing about that statement
many democrats don't even like those
ideals many democrats believe the ideals
themselves are racist they are tools of
oppression
there's a whole group of woke people in
the united states who believe that
freedom of the press
freedom of speech the rights to bear
arms these rights are in and of
themselves the threat
to you they're a threat to me they're a
threat to everything good and decent
the democratic party is moving in their
direction they'd rather make common
cause with those folks than defend
those core rights trump pointing that
out is definitely worthwhile
the other speech that president trump
gave that i thought was quite impactful
was in 2017
president trump spoke defending western
civilization in warsaw
he talked about russia's destabilizing
actions around the world
he praised the polish resistance and
naturally the left-wing media
immediately declared that this was white
nationalism and anti-muslim
anti-immigrant rhetoric because he
talked about the
glories of western civilization why
because
trump said that um when we were when he
was talking about western
accomplishments
he talked about art and symphonies and
all of this stuff and apparently that's
bad
that's very very bad you're not allowed
to talk about the greatness of western
civilization without the left
immediately labeling it white
supremacist which
shows the problem with the left if you
hate western civilization so much
that you believe that even it's
mentioned as a white supremacist dog
whistle
then you should not be trusted with the
keys to the car here is president trump
talking in defense of western
civilization
in poland in 2017 americans
polls and nations of europe value
individual freedom and sovereignty
we must work together to confront forces
whether they come from inside or out
from the south or the east
that threaten over time to undermine
these values
and to erase the bonds of culture faith
and tradition that make us who we are
okay that is true it is true and these
are challenges that are going to outlast
any election
the challenges to american philosophy
the challenges to western civilization
these are civilizational challenges they
are going to outlast
whatever happens between joe biden and
donald trump next week
it's going to require a re-education of
the american public and the foundational
principles of america
not re-education in the maoist sense not
indoctrination
a reacquaintance with founding principle
that has been completely obliterated
by a left that sees those foundational
principles as bad
the fact that trump spoke out about them
during his presidency is worthy of note
and the fact that his opponents hated
them so much is even more worthy of note
if trump has done nothing else
rhetorically he has certainly clarified
where people stand
trump is like a catalyzing enzyme he's
made everything quite clear
it is now very obvious where a lot of
people stand on american founding
philosophy on western civilization
regardless of whether you think trump
is a good defender of those things the
willingness of so many people to dump
over
those fundamental basic principles that
uphold everything good and the things
that we cherish
in the united states and abroad because
they hate trump
demonstrates that they don't have a lot
of feel to those principles in the first
place
all right we will be back here tomorrow
with much much more content
five days away from election day if you
have not yet voted go do it right now
this is the bench hero show
[Music]